foreign
yeah but I I was still kind of the first
one yeah
so so first I'm going to have to let's
plan first I'm going to give a teaser
about what we see today and then I'll
try to talk about some background on the
randomization like the so the written
approach of using targeted prg instead
of a prgs for doing demolition prg here
plan for pseudo-render generator
I'll Define them and then I'll talk
about a framework of constructing
packages prz via instance wise 100
Randomness connection which which is
going to be very useful when you apply
them to interactive proofs
but I'll talk about or without in more
detail
and I will will
finally I will get to the proof
hopefully
so so some teaser
so we're going to talk about something
called like freelance generalization of
all constant Ram doubly efficient proof
system it's okay if you don't know what
it means that I'll Define them pretty
soon but even though so essentially we
show that assuming strong but complexity
favor assumptions are constant round T
time T time means a very quiet time
doubly efficient proof systems can be
converted to a t to the OnePlus Epsilon
time MP type argument system by MP type
I mean the there's no interaction and
the verifier is domestic with a very
small block of improvements
um
WP which improved systems
so that's almost no overhead regardless
of the number to run and life as long as
it's constant yeah
so the key idea here is actually we
apply targeted prgs to a current
transcript to reduce the those
Randomness and the interaction of the
right fire so very much like 30 Shamir
but uh
with that very different analysis as
I'll
discuss this in detail later
the physics
for example
so so here's a very interesting chord
array so if you apply what I said to the
council run soundtrack protocol then
under the same hypothesis for all
Epsilon constant Epsilon that's a
verifier let's get an MP the formula of
the background size runs being 2 to the
Epsilon and time
and first is to accept some that's
correct proof
which make it output the correct
the correct number satisfying alignment
of the MP formula
second for every two to the OM time
proverb or anniversary the probability
that that the proverb the the fixed
proverb comes up with a
a formula and a round pool is very small
so in some sense we are refuting the
non-terministic eth but only for like an
average case notion of arguments
in the
probability is named so it's in the for
the Wi-Fi is completely optimistic yeah
so the project has just for this
recipe yeah t can be randomized this
only makes the payment Stronger Yeah
okay so but before I begin to describe I
want to fact about why that thermalation
have anything to do with me at all a
quick answer is well why not
I mean you want to replace that random
Oracle by an Express the hash function
right this is
I mean you think about you this is very
similar to your Malaysia or maybe it is
Generation
of course you are not getting a complete
annulation in many applications but you
are really reducing the amount of
revenues by a lot
second secondly like a more technical
reason is that if you can actually make
your proof system or argument system
deterministic then automatically you can
remove the induction because if you are
verifiers already deterministic then you
can then then prove I can always
understand the whole transcript then
there's no interaction so if you can do
generalization you get rid of the runs
of intact interactive induction
automatically
system
okay so another thing I want to
um
complexity favor assumptions means
so roughly speaking
the assumptions
speak about the existence of a function
I have had in a certain sense
so it's not really about aesthetic High
function like factoring or learning with
error but more or less about then it is
a personal function and having us in
some sense so it's pretty General
and second the running time of the heart
function is slightly larger than the
running time after adversary so this is
usually what what you'll mean by data
about complexity region yeah crypto prg
the rental the prg is much smaller than
the adversary
you mean the running time The Hard
Direction
if you have something like a one-way
function you mean the inversion it's
likely that's not the one for
adversaries
functions
Computing the prg is more expensive than
uh it's really some properties that
dissatisfied by a random functions
foreign
functions so unlike most of the crypto
assumptions
Okay so
yes so for example consider the crypto
prg printing one bit one
if you if I give you a string evaluated
equally to the PRT it takes like for
another time because the advanced story
can run in arbitrary whenever time is
stronger than the entity which runs the
PRT and that's what I mean
okay so now let's move to some
background on randomization
so
so the key concept of this talk is
something called targeted krg which in
sometimes you are trying to produce
super Randomness from the input instead
of the instant from the same air so let
me recall the definition of random
generators
let's say you have a circuit of a inside
circuit on empty input
I generate a prg g is going to
have a small seed lens and if you look
at all possible outputs so so S1 to SM
is like numeration of all possible seats
so all the strings from zero one to the
log M so log m is the students
and the
the generator does not depend on socket
C and we wanted to follow every small
circuit C so in other words the
accepting probability of every muscle
can see over that uniform input
is very close to the accepting
probability of C over the pseudo random
outputs
that's the standard definition of random
generator
prg is very similar to a prg except for
one thing and the generator actually now
depends on C so it it looks at C and
then outputs
sums the random outputs
and uh
and uh Now you kind of have a different
quantification it says that for every
small c g Sub C Force the second C
so again you let the requirements is
actually the same except for now you
have a subscription here means you can
dependency okay Stephen relating to all
the results so we miss unscriptions if
you look at the targeted version it is
it's not targeted so there is this old
result of civil humor that the observed
that you can use the Nissan spirg for
different optimization
and I think the high level point was
similar to the seed size can be reduced
from log Square to logarithmic
to allow it to depend on the algorithm
s
you you don't have domination you have a
description
you need to work with Facebook for every
philosophical right so I mean if you
have this thing if the ABM is polynomial
then you already have P equals right you
can answer it
so she cannot we just see
it
[Music]
just so the ideas are C is fixed ahead
of time and then you choose the
generator
I also I also uh
[Music]
let's say we have a linear time
randomized algorithm without empty input
and also MP3 of randomness
an input circular C sub X that is
defined by fixing the input part of a so
state of X it takes npw of Randomness
and the output whether a or input X
accept is running this
then almost by definition you just apply
G on its new circular set of X and then
you can enumerate all possible uh seeds
from S1 to SM assuming m is polynomial
then you get what you want then you can
decide to either accept or Not by
looking at this estimate
so pretty pretty easy right so so the
pattern lines now if you have this
targeted prg you can
so P equals VP
okay
you're trying to foresee like since the
distinguishes
production generator
in time right
okay
okay so
so this is uh you before you can apply
Target prg to your medication but we
really have what we really care about in
this park is to randomize proof system
proof systems instead of
algorithms so now let's say we have a
put standard proof system and ask the
modern type type proof system where
verifier always sends uniformly random
stream
and let's say the first
and random challenge is after one
and if we want to
replace the truly random first method
after the one by a pseudo-render message
first we need to ask ourselves in this
in a setting what distinguisher or test
do we want to fool so that we can ensure
the correctness of our of the of the
randomized proof system
right so if you think about it like the
lenses is the residual value of the
protocol or the games or the game
I'll Define it
so so more precisely I'll I'll try to be
able to use that targeted prg
that depends on the input X to generate
to the random messages G sub x s i
we replace
the first random message and here I
Define the r sub X of r as the maximum
accept probability of the value of fire
it will you fix the first challenge to
be r
exactly so then the acceptance
probability of the actual protocol is
going to be just a uniform uh
the expectation of usable X over
uniformly random messages and if you
replace that via output of random output
of targeted prg then then get the
the value of f of x over the random
distribution
and usually want this tool to be close
right so R sub X is going to be the top
the test or distinguisher you want to
follow here it's actually a real valued
distinguisher but you can pay some trick
to make a Boolean value but let's say
it's a real valuable one for now
so so for the first message we wish the
output of T sub X to full this residual
value
f of x
the question yeah does r of X depend on
the particular prover or that like uh so
okay so so we first we've we fix uh no
no that's like that not depend on the
prepare approver it's the maximum effect
probability
yeah yeah yeah yeah yes yes so that's
not efficient the computable right
um depends on the it depends on put on
the proof system for some check I think
it is
so
I don't know exactly uh I think uh you
only have it let's say time bound on the
proverb or something yeah
so you fixed the first message and then
you I can assume you choose the best
for that first message
yes
sorry of course
um
that's not the poor
space just this function f of x you know
it's function this only depends on x
right and selection on the best element
of protocol on excellent the best
possible yeah
yeah this may not be you can become
visible or arbitrary afterwards system
yes this question um is this an
inconsistency between R1 and R1
since R1 is the first message or
oh
so uh okay maybe a little bad index but
I want this means the message in the
first round it's actually the other one
right it's a general description foreign
transcript let's let's let the note TR
sub at most one to be the current
transcript up to the first round then
you the verifier is going to apply a
Target PRT based on a current transcript
to generate another through random
message distribution to replace artwork
asset tool
again here you want to follow the second
residual value of the game which only
depends on current transcript
so now you want to uh so after the
transcript is fixed you want to show
that the your second to the random
distribution first this second residual
value of the game
so don't you need the targeted prg to be
efficient getting the target namely
given transcript small or equal to one
Computing G sub transcript is efficient
yes of course yeah cannot run it yeah
exactly yeah
yeah I'm just yeah I'm just trying to
make it more looks better
for the second let's do a value and you
can keep doing this
so for every round T you are targeted
prg to generate the student render
message at around t
and you apply it uh the entire PLC takes
the current transcript as the input
so finally this is going to reduce the
total randomness of V to c times S Sub D
so C is the number of runs s w the
dividends of the targeted prg the
protocol can then be made non-tractive
and domestic with a blowout of 2 to the
c times S Sub G you can simply enumerate
all possible Randomness and that the
program is just going to send you the
strategy the hostility tree
so so we'll actually make S7
logarithmic therefore the whole product
is small
because it's
I don't understand how do you know there
exists a targeted G for this residual
function which might not even be
computable oh that's a really of course
we need to assume some kind of
assumption right but you will construct
it for specific
protocols or uh well I guess
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh uh I uh yes yes which means that you
need it for the computation for the
previous slide to also be close to
linear
um foreign
[Music]
but why would the prover would be more
expensive
they don't like this okay
yeah great talk to them inspired
discussion
all right
maybe as compared with the original
fashion mirror and let me see a bit um
what's different and what's similar
render Oracle version of the affiliation
protocol you just replace the actual
random message by a pseudo render method
in some sense uh which is a right
uniformly render Oracle
and the on the applied to the transcript
so one can instantiate this from the
Oracle by Express the correlation
intractable Heights function uh with a
key so here the height function comes
with that random key at least stand by
the verifier at the beginning
so you know our approach actually that's
no random key at the beginning uh the
but we are allow some small amount of
Randomness per round and after
collapsing the round by enumerating all
possible Randomness B is actually made
dynamistic so uh so if you apply
correlation you try to hatch function
you actually get an awesome type of
proof system okay it's like more like
more like an MP type argument system
so if I understand correctly we're not
talking about the general Paradigm but
is this how different is it from like
other previous results about the
randomizing interactive complexity
classes like I write am and things like
this this already studied in the various
challenges sorry they all use it so what
we first do you first compress the
rounds and then just use the prg-1
yes
I see so like so before there was no
case where people had to sort of be
randomize and multi-round
[Music]
protocol
um you know by doing it uh one round at
a time
um I think you can do that too in a
previous approach but they don't really
buy you anything I'll say why like you
got security right they don't really
help you okay
that's a way to
to get some argument system which are
much faster with a much faster product a
verifier time
I guess we're not talking about results
you're talking about definitions right
like what kind of subram generator do
you need in order to randomize like this
in interactive process right yeah and
that's what yeah that is well started
if you use prg then you cannot get a
very efficient uh
the music argument you can only get
something with a big problem
you cannot get like it's impossible to
get or people I mean you cannot prove
it's impossible but uh It seems
impossible so what is different than the
blueprint that you describe that you use
the targeted yeah okay so you're saying
okay now let's think of the targeted uh
uh notion in the context of an
interactive yeah yeah yes it's more like
fashion yeah
right that's not people always yeah yeah
you know proof system and so a
randomized proof system into a
deterministic proof system so that's
what that's yeah
argument actually so it's not going to
convert randomized from system into
empty type arguments overhead
time
Wilson
that usually you assume hardness of a
single output function f against
non-informed circuits
then you construct a prg g to the F so T
depends on F at first or small circuits
so behind the scene what's really
happening is a constructive
counter positive of what you want what
you want so they actually show that the
list is the D to the f is accompanied
with a small reconstruction Oracle
circuit add to the D such that
give any article that is not followed by
this PRT
this new construction Oracle circuit
even is a distinguisher that's called it
computes as exactly
so you know if you look at so if G to
the F that's not full some small circuit
we just plug in the small circuit to
this R you'll get a small circuit for f
so that's contradict your highness
assumption so therefore this uh
constructive contraceptive of the
statement you want uh gives you a PRT
construction starting from uh heart
functions
so so yeah original works
are you saying that there's something
different here in this constructed
positive than the current organisms
so
okay so okay so let's have a new thing
so so this one gives you prg but we want
targeted API of course so so what do we
do essentially you assume now you assume
hardness of
multi-output function f let's say F Maps
n Bits to MPS or mb2 into Epsilon bits
against uniform algorithms algorithms
and a particular input V
this gives you
a Target PRT C to the F so T depends on
F and the C other takes Z as the input
that first are a small small uniform
algorithms on inputed by smart let's say
the UniBank algorithm rusting T time
then the generator maybe runs in poly T
time or t to the one plus Epsilon time
so how do we so how do you get this
so
maybe a better way to I mean a
particular input sounds uh a little bit
hard to formalize a better way to
formalize this is the kind of thing
about distributions right so if you have
a if you have a 100 output function f
against uniform algorithm over input
from particular distribution t
then this gives you a targeted PRT and
of course All Uniform algorithms over
input from this the same distribution d
so that's a precise translation between
the hardness distribution and the
distribution that you can de randomize
but how so how do how do you get this
type of very tight connection between
hardness and the to the randomness
so we'll have an instance-wise
constructive contrapositive
such that let's talk to the prg again is
accompanied with a small reconstruction
Oracle algorithm
that passed by the following sovereign
can be computed by a fast algorithm
defined by you replacing this
Oracle the Oracle here by a 16z as input
level you can think about distribution
so you will the
u t to the F does not fall uh
uniform algorithm over some distribution
then
it can be computed on that distribution
okay
oh yes yes so yes so I uniform uniform
you want to be randomize a uniform and
an algorithm the a takes two inputs x d
and r so this is the input as randomness
and the the targeted PRT if you want to
randomize a and into the Z you you fix
the input the first SD and you plug in
the suit random outputs at the second
input so if a with Z6 is the
distinguisher I want to four here
[Music]
this actually depends on zero yes yes
I think here I didn't write it yes
I think this is the most important uh
technical takeaway of the the new
framework so essentially uh I mean it's
fine to forget this but the point is
that you have a uh
translation of kindness to surrenderness
and preserve the heart distribution and
it actually works input per input if you
are functioning High honestly your
alternation works on quickly
can you like repeat the tree the trick
again please can you repeat the trick
again like what's the key takeaway that
you said something okay you have a
translations
works on the same input yes
yes
[Music]
foreign
construction to the setting of impactive
proofs
um
what was this maximum overall approval
messages so that kind of is
yes yes so you need a stronger highness
assumption yes but the key is man you
can have a new test-wise transformation
between kindness and radius
you're supposed to get a correctness
or all cases how do you get worst case
correctness oh and we'll actually get it
exactly over any predominant time sample
distribution
foreign
systems in which only efficient
algorithms are allowed to enter the
verifier is very efficient in the sense
that the verifier takes quality of time
in the input lens let's see and the
company completeness is attained by a
polynomial time Proverbs and the
soundness is against every polynomial
time adversary
so that's a generation of
um
argument system
uh yes yes I'll I'll show the product
definition so
so uh so so
in previous local study efficient
improve systems for both Partners in P
or publishing MP and uh but in in those
previous work the verifier they are they
are always randomized but very fast
so here so let's talk about what what
well
um
MP type of argument system where the the
verifier is actually deterministic
we are studied for both popular GMP or
publishing MP but let's focus on
problems in P in this club
so the preset definition of what about
witch and proof system so here a
language has a doubly efficient uh
interactive proof system of time T if
that's a t-time verifier and a
polynomial time polynomial T time prover
such that if x is in L then this honest
proverb can convince verifier with
probability one
yes
and uh
and if x is nothing ill then for every
uh for every poor uh even unbounded one
the probability of the P Prime accept
convince V is small
so we'll so we relax the definition in
in two ways so first we are we'll we
actually allow unnoticeable error in the
sense that in the science case now we
only assume for every polynomial T time
randomized adversary they cannot come up
with a bad input and a proof such that
it had a trick the verifier into
believing a false statement
so here the the adversary is uniform
they
it cannot generate a bad input and a
better proof such that that is nothing
ill and somehow B believes the answer is
yes
so so that two ways the the we make like
feature first you make information
theoretical soundness to you know
conversational second you also make the
the time average case notion this other
two substance is kind of inherent once
you talk about even foreign yes because
if you
allow normal diversary you can always
yeah so
so
all precise theorem stays like under 100
assumption we'll see later for every
constant C uh and a polynomial time T
constant say around
W efficient inductive proof system can
be
randomized into a
with a smart overhead so here we remove
remove both the randomness and also the
wrong number of rounds
and uh as a Corollary
so
so now let's remind you of the so as a
very very color where you can apply what
I said to the thumb check protocol for
substance to get this thing I showed you
at the beginning of the of the talk
another triple app
uh system for bundle space delegation
okay Reserve our first messages
to twice more then assuming the
brightness is very small the the poorer
can just send us value function
otherwise it doesn't work
okay so now let's get to the
the proof overview
okay so so before talking about the real
proof I don't want to talk about why PRT
doesn't work because I mean because so
we are trying to change something new so
we have to justify why the previous you
know uh
so the first attempt to randomize the
the interactive system is just you use
that PRT at each turn right so this can
of course reduce the amount of
Randomness but if you think about it
you'll realize the distinguisher here is
the residual value of the game
and the residual value of the game
depends on the current transcript that
can be total two bits of the transcript
so that can be 2 to the T magnetic
distinguisher because you want to fold
them out this actually means you really
have to pay log t
C at each round
this is too much you don't you you don't
want to pay log T C at each round
because then if you have stayed around
the total uh the total number of
kubernetes three times Logitech
you want something logarithmic
so you don't want to use a prg
so
okay but the next it doesn't know about
your manual now you can say okay but in
fact we don't have to for every possible
transcript right the because in all
definition the transcript include
including the input is always Sample
about one polynomial time polynomial T
time distribution
so perhaps we can just apply a prg at
first uh our polynomial T-Type algorithm
uh this also doesn't work because we are
in a complexity region and if you want
to full quality time algorithms you have
to pay also yeah you also have to pay
Omega at least log tested
so so PRT doesn't really work
of course you cannot approve the uh the
rigorous if they don't work because
that's probably in part time developer
but uh
just straightforward they don't seem to
work
so you think about it the so why we why
the pi doesn't work is because
essentially if you use a prg the PRT
does not know the transcripts you want
you want a single
generator at first all possible at the
works against all possible transcripts
that's too much to hope for
uh yes
uh yeah
I think so
yes okay the problem is not about the
city it's about the running time of the
prg yeah because we are in a combative
region at the right time it's actually
slightly larger than polity yeah
so the solution here now we just we're
not we use a targeted API that gets a
specific transcript as expected input
and then we force the residual value UPS
again for that particular transcript we
don't attempt to
value for every possible transcript
that's just too much we really want to
be more specific and work with the
current uh transcript
now knows the current transcript
and so now let's get to the proof
so of course that
and you simplify things like this so
that I can have time to cover the cover
something interesting so we'll first
assume the verifier only use like R to
the and to the o1 coins this is this
this is true for the sunshine protocol
because you only toss a small amount of
coin in there
and second until they base showcase the
main idea and suffices for the shock
sets application the general case you
you actually first apply uh some
additional kind of assumption to reduce
the amount of Readiness from T to to
enter 01 then you can apply this
simplified uh you can go you can work
with the simplified setting
so we assuming number of Readiness per
round is small
is a constant
ly how many
so the building plot here is that so we
first we assume we have a hard function
it Maps the transcript the tidbit let's
transcript Z to poly R many bits so I is
the number of is the polynomial it's a
number of Rangers per round and the F
from T2 tips to KB is compatible in t
times per decay
take time domestically and it's hard for
a lot for some lower time and we'll see
the required property in a moment
and then the construction what we will
do is that we'll apply the Nissan which
is a generator with the F of Z as the
hard truth table
and alternative PRT is just going to be
the so our input on transcript Z you get
F of Z then you apply Nissan widget to
get uh some super random outputs the
point is that F sub Z is only poly it's
only poorly upbeats I is into the with
o1 so so here you only have n to the
little o1 many outputs
what is the property of this
construction so uh I'm not going to I'm
not going to give you the proof but the
the only thing we need is that assume
that each bit of s is compatible in time
T Prime then that exists are
construction algorithm such that it runs
in K times K to the little K to the
0.001 times T Prime Time such that for
every distinguisher that breaks this
left and Generator you the
reconstruction with the Oracle as a
distinguisher can compute an approximate
version of f sub of F2 FD so here the
randomness is over I for one two k and
also random random coins used by the
Reconstruction algorithm
so in some sense it says that if the
actually so this shows that if the
if it had to print an approximation
approximate version of the entire string
F of Z in time catch the
0.001 times T Prime with Oracle Excel to
a distinguisher thing about it as the
residual value of the game then the
targeted PRT on the works
because we have a reconstruction just
plug in the residual value as the
distinguisher
foreign
as a learning algorithm
then you can learn a small truth about F
of Z and then you can evaluate this
modules table but I'm not going to talk
about in detail you can check the this
is some standard stuff in complexity
because you can check our proof for more
details okay so for more details
Okay so
the result
and that's a big Oracle
uh yes
it depends so if you work with the sound
check protocol like it is kind of
convertible
uh
in some sense
the Assumption will not be specifiable
the applicable there's some check or
something with every efficient
delegation system like it's going to be
possible
foreign
[Music]
that's exponential in the number of
witnesses
with a sharp set result I mean you're
applying this to a
foreign
to the transcript
is only say over two times all of logs
log K where K is the
output the length of the height function
so how do we make the
log in then we can collapse the protocol
type to our mp1 by standing at a tree of
all possible transcripts in advance so
this gives you T times n2201 argument
that means argument system yes
somehow use like a correlated uh
Tehran that actually you can make it for
like a more than customer yeah
per round to be independent here
but as I said before before this is
something was similar to the five
channel heuristic where you instead of a
random hash function used for
correlation intractable height function
you use typical prg
so so finally Let's uh tonight be
presented about highest assumption so so
where do transcripts come from yeah
definitely efficient argument system so
recall that the program is to come up
with a bad input and that bad proof so
in that sense the whole transcript
after the after the
the whole transcript of the agreement
system is going to be polynomial time
sampling
because you can run the back to work
right
so what we really want is that this High
function f is hard with high probability
over upper normal time sample level
distributions
then with high probability so if you fix
a unit from Vancouver then with high
probability over the Readiness of the
bad approver f is going to be hard on a
transcript generated from the
interaction then you can apply this
target prg to to do a demolition
so the residue a distinguisher and so
the distinguisher is the rescue body of
the game and
so we now we need 100 assumption to be f
is hard over up number time sampler
distribution that is
approximately how to print with the
that's the value of the game given as
the Oracle and the last value is the
real value function but you can make it
uh
simple manipulation
so finally to finish the proof we use a
subtle hybrid argument to gradually
replace random coins to the random one
round by round and we also need to be
careful with the definition of the
approval and the
approval and the wheel and we are going
to transform the real value
distinguisher to our Boolean one
I think I'm going to uh
okay
in the last few years I mean Global open
published
so we talked about Agreement System that
had artistic and the secure only on
average which seems to be we seem to be
new at five we know so and also they
seem pretty natural because it's like a
natural uh
conditional version of MP so maybe that
can more can be said about them in
general and I can study them for more
like 20 years almost okay okay it's just
called uniform soundness
um
and we came out complexity is
theoretical analysis of biceps
and this might be interesting
as well and uh also a very interesting
open question that we can get subset in
this this domestic argument with some
expansion running time but can you can
get it with a polynomial running time
that'd be very interesting and that
seems uh pretty hard
finally our assumptions are stupid are a
little bit at the hawk so
it's very interesting to get a nicer
nicer assumption better imply the same
result also maybe at least some weaker
version of assumptions are necessary
and then in general I think the the new
the new framework I've used impacted prg
is very interesting so maybe we'll come
up with the entirely new assumptions and
give you the required Target prg and
then can use them
yeah thanks
if there's any hope of uh producing your
current assumption
I mean if you're into you like you will
talk about those
[Music]
things I don't know I mean
yeah and also in crypto usually you
usually use at least some average case
or something if you don't have worst
case to Advocate reductions
any other questions so I'm still
confused is Computing the prg that you
get is it faster or slower than
Computing the residual function
so if
okay so so the the so the things that
the the residual value is available at
Key time to systems well I just talked
about that one pass absolute time
algorithm so the the target is available
in a lot of time but the but also you
cannot simulate a system to system in
like a general algorithm so it's like
it's a special Computing the rest of the
residual that residual function right
that would be uh
foreign
okay so let's take a 30 minute break
thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign